what's going on everybody welcome to the
10th Python with matplotlib for data
visualization tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about some
real basic customizations of this graph
mainly rotating that the labels and the
axes but also how we actually start
building the actual sub plot in the
figure and all that so let's go ahead
and just hop right in first of all when
you're building graphs there's really
two two major ways that you can have
multiple sub plots and we'll be talking
about those later on but for now we'll
just use one of them also implied when
you make a graph is this figure I'm
going to put fig equals PLT dot figure
here and that's just again that's just
kind of like an an implied thing you
don't have to have it there but if you
want to start modifying the figure you
have to reference the figure somehow so
that's how we do it so PLT dot figure
just are automatically already existed
but this is how you can begin to modify
it if you want now Figg equals that and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to find ax 1 a lot of people just
say ax and then if they add more it's
like ax 2 and stuff I prefer to have
like ax 1 X 2 X 3 do whatever you want
it's not a big deal so X 1 equals and
then we're going to say PLT dot sub plot
to grid and this is just one of the ways
where we can have many subplots for now
we're just gonna have one but this the
first like little pair here this first
tuple is the shape of the grid basically
it's a 1x1 okay and then the second
tuple is the starting point of this plot
0 0 and then there's a few others here
there's row span and column span we
don't need it we're just doing one by
one here it's not necessary so we're not
going to really add anything else there
now what we're going to do is now that
we've got ax 1 ax 1 is what we plot to
not PLT so this is our first axes we're
going to plot to that so instead of PLT
dot plot we do a X 1 dot plot so ax 1 is
a sub plot it's going to take up as much
space as all the other plots that we've
done it's just a sub plot so when we
have
PLT dot X label and Y label and all that
what's happening there is we can leave
that there most likely that should be
fine later on we'll talk about how you
can have you know like if you've got
multiple plots how do you put the labels
there and all that we'll get to that but
for now mainly what we have to change is
the is what we're plotting so we've got
that now let's go ahead and run that and
make sure everything works up to this
point before we do one more modification
okay so everything's looking good the
labels are where they want to be where
we want them and all of that what we
want to do now is rotate the dates here
and if we rotate them slightly we could
fit a lot more dates but also they'll
pretty much never run over each other
like they do like in this example okay
so we want to rotate them and rotating
them is not too bad it just takes a
little modification but like I was
telling you everything a matplotlib is
customizable it's really really well
thought out so on ax one we do this we
do the plot run underneath that we're
going to say for label in ax 1 dot x
axes dot get underscore tick labels so
this gets all those little objects that
constitute these tick labels and then
what we can do is we can modify them so
label dot we can do label that set
underscore rotation rotation and then we
set the degrees of the rotation so we
set amount of 45 degrees so that should
be it's like a perfect slant
so we're modifying each label as eat
they're like objects and these get tick
labels and then we're using this set
rotation method to set their tilt
basically another interesting thing that
we can go ahead and show is well well
let's let's bring this one up and then
I'll show one more thing and then we'll
close this one out so now they're like
kind of tilted like that so it's pretty
cool so now we can zoom in and then we
start finding we got one more problem
now so we're tilted they're not running
over each other but dang it they're off
the screen so like I was saying before
- we would use this configure subplots
and then we can see that ok we'll let
see they're falling off the bottom so
let's modify the bottom a little bit
give it a little more space and that
looks about good
so really the bottom needs to be 0.18
let's say and then we could bring some
of these other things over but let's
just do the bottom for an hour we'll do
them all I guess but let's just close
this out and let's just let's start
modifying those so we close close close
and coming down to basically the very
very bottom here I usually do it I tend
to like keep everything clumped together
so first you know you've defined your
figure you define all your axes then you
define your date or your data sorry so
your data goes there and then you start
defining everything that goes on to each
individual subplot which is your axes so
all the ax 1 stuff will go here and then
if we have when and if we have ax 2
you'll have a clump ax 2 stuff and then
X 3 and so on so and then at the bottom
all the specific you know PLT stuff
that's going to apply across the entire
graph you put that stuff down here so
we're going to do PLT dot sub plots
underscore adjust and then here we put
all the parameters now we'll just kind
of throw some in here and we'll throw
them all in here and then later on we
can adjust them as needed
so we'll say left equals zero point nine
bottom will be equal to 0.16 right will
be equal to 0.94 and that needs to be
right not right then we got top zero
point two equals zero point nine five W
space equals four now we'll just do zero
point two and then H space equals zero
we'll talk about that later but
basically this and this we're not even
going to see but once you have multiple
figures it's like padding between the
figures you got top padding and side
padding that's what that is
so with that the bottom I think we said
with the bottom should be 18 actually so
I'll do 18 and the rest should be fine
so let's go ahead and run that now what
have we done okay so the left is screwed
up some houses uh left zero point zero
I'm try again okay that's better so uh
we were kind of squishing the top a bit
that's okay we'll bring that down and
then like if we zoom in here even with
like full date although as we zoom and
we're still running out of space so we
can give the bottom maybe a little bit
more let's do 20 and then top needed a
little more space let's do top is a nine
three let's do that see how that works
out
let's do nine zero okay and then let's
zoom in a little bit okay sounds good
enough let's zoom into a time - yeah so
everything else that's all looking good
we've got the date the time the titles
fit the labels are fitting we're all
good
the only other thing I want to show is
like okay so say we're we're like we're
looking at prices but we're like okay
well what's the price right here right
we could put our mouse over that I guess
and you can read in the bottom the
bottom right corner you can see okay y
equals 190 but what if you just like
want to visually look at that well
generally we have a grid okay so we can
add a grid really simply by doing and we
can add this by chart so we would say a
X 1 dot grid and then in here we just
put true so we save and run that and up
pops a chart and it's got a grid now the
grid can also be customized a lot like
your lines that you might plot so for
example week is a true week is a color
and we can say the color is equal to G
or green we can also say line style
equals and instead of that - we could
say it's a solid line so let's run that
one for now
okay so now it's this green grid and
then we could take it a step further an
absurdity
and we could say line width equals five
okay so you can do all kinds of crazy
stuff okay with the grid generally just
grid equals true is good enough so I'm
just going to close this off here and
comment the rest of that out but you can
take note that you can do all these
other things if you want along those
same lines I'm going to go ahead and
take the
and get rid of all this wasted space
I'll save this for now and then probably
will get rid of that line shortly but
anyways so now we've customized the
chart a little bit obviously we saw have
a long way to go in customization but
there's some basic starting points for
customizing and pulling data offline and
getting a relatively ok looking chart
but we have a lot of fun things to cover
I promise so anyways if you have any
questions comments concerns whatever up
into this point please feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time